okay i got to speak on behalf of the
beehive because i am a card-carrying
member of the bee house unapologetically
here's what i have to say and i love
j-lo too don't get me wrong but i think
as a cultural
icon it is your responsibility to be
aware of
cultural references and that is one of
the most iconic
performances and looks of recent history
and it's also recent history that was
six years ago we remember that i
remember dancing around my room
with my hair like that i mean it's too
close for comfort
comfort and i think that i'm not
surprised by the backlash
elaine do you think you know what i
think i
was wondering um because i agree with
you elaine like i think
when you're doing a performance you need
to know what's going on but do you guys
think
possibly that maybe she had a creative
director
that gave her this reference and maybe
she didn't even
you know what i'm saying maybe she got
this plan because sometimes that could
happen
if someone i don't know how j.lo's team
works at all
and how involved or not involved she is
but sometimes creative direct directors
come up with certain things and then
pitch it bled over and pitched but i
have to say
watching those two together you
definitely are like
dang but my big issue is all i want is
my ass to look like that in a sheer
onesie
[Applause]
just to go back to your point um eve
nappy tabs is the creative director for
jlo
but i want to point out like look they
look to me they look a lot alike and i
think
they should have done a little bit more
research right but
this this has been around for a long
time there's a show called crazy horse
in paris
that is known for like casting beautiful
women with beautiful bodies and it's all
about the lighting effect
so this there's pictures floating around
the internet that you can see it's
almost exactly the same kind of lighting
and then you have to kind of go back
even further to 1972 when you think
about fosse and cabaret they're stealing
the kind of idea
i think the problem with this one is
that it was like the hair
and the look and the lighting all at
once that made it very recognizably
similar to something that just happened
quite recently
so but it's interesting you know this
happens all the time this is oh you've
seen some
creative plagiarism haven't you at some
point oh no you didn't call it creation
he said creative language
um listen her performance was great her
performances
always are great but you know that when
you saw the cross
of lighting her face aussie's been doing
that for years
hold on did i create that no
i stole it off someone else oh
this is like usher's confessions up here
everybody's telling me
that you know that's the way it goes but
i think she went a little
too far on the beyonce thing
but listen the performance was great but
you know i think we all steal
you